truth is everything in YouTube is very
simple but the simplest thing is
difficult if we want to be unstoppable
and have an Unstoppable mindset we
actually have to guard our minds we need
to guard our hearts we need to protect
our Focus the key is that even if you
have these big wins that yes you
celebrate yes you enjoy it but how
quickly do you get back to Baseline and
get back to work
there's one thing that all content
creators and business owners have in
common and that is that they face
discouragement on the journey it's hard
to start a YouTube channel it's hard to
start a business it's hard to spend your
extra time after your nine to five
building a side hustle so how do you
ultimately build an Unstoppable mindset
and mental toughness that can crash
through quitting points well in this
episode I'm going to be sharing three
proven principles for becoming an
Unstoppable content creator in our
Series where we're learning from
military strategists like General Carl
Vaughn cloutswitz being unstoppable
means you refuse to quit it means you
are ready to adapt and pivot in the
midst of changing economic and cultural
conditions it's mental toughness that is
able to show up and get results even if
there is drama all around you from
friends family and colleagues it's
resilience grit and staying cool under
pressure and so what lessons can we
learn from the general today when it
comes to being Unstoppable number one
Focus your energy and resources here's
the quote the talent of the strategist
is to identify the decisive point and to
concentrate everything on it removing
forces from secondary fronts and
ignoring lesser objectives General Klaus
wits would encourage us to avoid
distractions at all costs one of my
favorite Bible verses is above all else
guard your heart for it is the
Wellspring of life if we want to be
unstoppable and have an Unstoppable
mindset we actually have to guard our
minds we need to guard our hearts we
need to protect our focus and so the
talented strategist when it comes to
YouTube when it comes to building an
online business is going to focus their
energy figure out what battles should
they be fighting and what battles should
they be avoiding when you know you're
right battles and you have a a Clear
Vision that's where you want to
concentrate your energy but what I love
about this quote is removing forces from
secondary fronts is there arguments
you're in that are a waste of your time
and that are stealing your emotional
strength are you getting stuck on
Facebook debating with friends or family
members or strangers about politics in
unwinnable battles are you investing
energy in lesser objectives are you
ignoring the more important objectives
if you want to be unstoppable Focus your
energy and resources on the right things
number two stay stoic here's the quote
from the general a strong character is
one that will not be unbalanced by the
most powerful emotions you know a lot of
these things are easier said than done
and I don't know about you but depending
on what challenges and setbacks come in
a day depends on maybe the emotions that
you feel that can knock you off
track have you ever been seeing red in
Anger have you ever been feeling like
there's a million pound weight on your
chest or your shoulders because you're
discouraged the truth is all of us as
content creators to varying degrees
experience powerful emotions if you
start a business you start a YouTube
channel you're gonna face all kinds of
powerful emotions discouragement
setbacks wanting to quit anger rage
could be jealousy could be envy could be
very powerful emotions Peak emotions of
excitement of Love of feeling Joy of
feeling happiness but the lesson that we
learn as it pertains to creating content
on YouTube is not getting unbalanced by
the high emotions or the low emotions
and that ultimately we should stay stoic
this reminds me of a book I was reading
recently called attributes it's actually
written by a Navy SEAL I highly
recommend it and we'll link that one up
in the show notes as well as the book on
war that we've been covering in this
series it's pretty crazy but if you want
to check it out you can always check out
these resources in the show notes but in
this book on attributes one of the
chapters was about resilience now I'd
heard the word resilience a lot I kind
of just thought it meant like don't quit
it just meant like you're really gritty
you just don't quit you keep going but
the actual definition of resilience is
the capacity to withstand or to recover
quickly from difficulties it's the
ability of a substance or object to
spring back into shape elasticity that's
the dictionary definition and the way
the author of the book attributes
explained it was he said if you have
this strong character resilience is if
you're on a high you just got that you
know plaque on YouTube maybe you just
hit a record you got your first 1000
subscribers maybe you got the silver
plaque in the mail you hit a hundred
thousand you just had you just got
monitor ties you maybe just had a viral
video you're on some Peak emotion maybe
you not only are doing well on YouTube
but you came home and like your spouse
your partner's pumped and like they were
super encouraging you just been like
hitting gold it's just you're on some
momentum the key is that even if you
have these big wins that yes you
celebrate yes you enjoy it but how
quickly do you get back to Baseline and
get back to work elasticity back to not
letting success go to your head not
letting success make you prideful make
your ego inflated and maybe make you
feel entitled to the victory that you
just won we've learned that yesterday's
home runs do not win today's games so
resilience is even on a high how quickly
do you get back to Baseline and then
similarly we've all been there where
maybe it's like the last 10 videos just
haven't hit the YouTube channel ad
revenues down the views are down your
business is down and then maybe you you
have maybe you're experiencing some
chronic pain you're facing a Health
Challenge you're facing some struggles
with some aging parents you're just in a
season of intense challenge how quickly
can you get back to Baseline
acknowledging those emotions processing
them praying through them getting
planted in church being in counseling
like doing all the things but as a
leader you still have to show up and get
results as a leader you may get some
horrible no's right before you have to
step on stage or step on camera and
actually deliver so ultimately
resilience as an attribute becomes one
of those critical components of staying
consistent through every season the
highs and the lows staying stoic a
strong character is one that will not be
unbalanced by the most powerful of
emotions either high or low number three
do hard things here's the quote from the
general
everything in war is very simple but the
simplest thing is difficult
this is good for us as YouTube content
creators because at the end of the day
if you've been a part of the think media
podcast for any length of time I know a
lot of our video ranking Academy members
listen to this podcast every week and if
you're here with me in this moment you
probably know a lot of the next steps
you need to do like I realize like
there's still other strategies you're
still working it out but you know that
you need to go post that next video you
know that you need to sit down and maybe
study design for a while like learn how
to actually use canva and maybe take a
skillshare course or Join one of our
programs get our YouTube starter kit and
like actually like level up your
thumbnail game like you know the simple
things you need to do the truth is
everything in YouTube is very simple but
the simplest thing is difficult friend
this is your reminder to do hard things
the best way to start a YouTube channel
is to actually start your YouTube
channel the best way to create momentum
this month on YouTube is to go shoot
your next video get it edited get it
uploaded and then multiply how many
uploads you're gonna do the best way to
get some momentum on your channel is to
sit down and get clear on your goals
again and then do the hard work of
following through on your goals a lot of
information is Flowing on the interwebs
these days all kinds of information is
out there and the information is good
and the strategies are important but you
and I both know that ultimately even the
simple things are hard because it comes
down to implementation not just
information there's a famous quote that
says success is one percent inspiration
and 99
perspiration it's the sweat it's the
getting up and being like crap my back
hurts and I don't really feel like
filming today but figuring it out
getting up and filming the videos it's
about getting up and doing the work work
that it takes to learn these skills to
study your Marketplace to study your
Niche or your competitors and do some
competitive analysis to take those
insights and then apply them to your
content it's about doing the hard work
of doing the things you don't want to do
in your business like setting it up
properly and eventually incorporating
into an LLC and getting your books right
and actually tracking your numbers and
doing some stuff that you don't want to
do why because it's hard but you got to
do hard things everything in YouTube is
very simple but the simplest thing is
difficult and so those are three proven
principles for becoming Unstoppable as a
content creator and if you actually want
some more help building some momentum on
YouTube right now especially because you
may feel like okay I'm kind of feeling
pumped and charged and I want to get to
work but I want to get to work smart we
actually have a free on-demand class at
thinkmasterclass.com that will help you
not just approach YouTube with random
energy and effort but to put together a
real strategy I love this military Strat
series that we're doing because strategy
is everything it's not just about haste
makes mistakes and running into the
battlefield with no plan it's like let's
sit down and actually make a plan so
that you can have confidence and energy
as you take Massive Action so if you
want to watch that on demand it's free
at thinkmasterclass.com I break down the
one strategy we're using at think media
right now that's actually generating
around 350 000 views a day even if we
don't upload new videos I'll show you
how we do it step by step you can check
that out and I'll link that up in the
show notes and if you enjoyed this
series check out part one and two we'll
put the whole playlist and links to the
Past episode in the show notes like rate
and review the podcast wherever you
watch or listen I appreciate you so much
want to send you love and respect today
and I can't wait to connect with you in
a future episode